foreign
hey Jack
how's your leg
s wagon
hey Ray
hey we saw your visitors she just had
some visitors yeah yeah we saw them on
the way up
[Applause]
hey Timmy
no no
okay
[Music]
I need your knees bugging you again
where's Larry
Larry be coming soon
there he's gone all day yeah
[Music]
oh
there you go
we got some pizzas
the dog is hungry
[Applause]
[Music]
Hillary
you okay
here's Lauren's like family now
the State Fair
race race that's something for you
Lauren
oh yeah did you hear
yourself
you want to sit down
you've really set up on the porch with
us
this dessert
[Music]
here I'll give you a pizza
you want some pizza
no
I'm ready oh you're busy
you guys should say it didn't it you
guys just ate didn't you no no they
didn't eat gay
excuse me
so Jack's okay
the dog is okay
missing a leg Yeah yeah
oh
yeah just Tails wagon
everybody gave me every morning
wow right
[Music]
there you go
what are you watching
oh
thank you Ray
I'm not sure I'm gonna sit on that
white girls
dude
your legs hurting
oh it hurts that bad
it hurts oh
you like to lay down right
thank you
yeah yeah maybe uh maybe you should see
a dog for that I'll talk to Betty about
it
should we see a doctor about his knee
should Ray see a doctor about his knee
okay no but you think maybe that's
something you should do
what do you know how he heard it
how do you hurt his knee all right
let's go arthritis
[Music]
you got a hurricane
so Betty tell me Larry was telling me
the other day about the house
next door tell me about the house next
door
you guys want to get the house next door
this one this one's starting to smell a
little bit
yeah the house next door it's beautiful
looks brand new I'm ready
how much they went for
well
okay what a lot of a lot of boys I
forgot how much it was they gave you a
prize
they gave me a price and I lost them
I think Larry said something like 219
219. I think Larry said something like
219 000. yeah
yeah maybe you can get it for a little
less
that's probably what it was
it'd be nice for you guys because this
one's getting pretty run down
make you happy yeah I'm happy no that
would make you happy to get over there
to move yeah next door
it keeps you in the neighborhood
yeah they even better place one yeah
well maybe we can get people to donate
people love your family I don't know you
get visitors you can visit us all the
time now I know you like it yeah I like
it they're always nice used to get
visitors that weren't so nice right yeah
years before you know years before I was
around well I've been picking guys out
here they wouldn't meet us today so
tell a woman out here they're on his
wife
was in the hospital and he together nice
people because Betty and tea because my
her talk shows Once a while yeah
everybody's nice it seems
down
they bring you gifts
and chips and a couple times and
applesauce okay
it's a thought that counts I have water
and some water
Lorraine how you doing
okay
she was talking to me when I walked in
yeah
Lauren had a good time with you at the
state fair I never saw her smile so much
yeah she was smiling big
buggy
you guys want some pizza
you almost got it down
tell me what you're drawing
hmm
okay sorry
no no no don't use that don't eat that
thing hear me
you guys are hungry now
come on
it's good timing
hey Larry
yeah we're going back tomorrow
just thought I'd come talk to Betty
about the house
[Music]
oh
how much is that house next door how
much is that house next door uh 219. 219
is that they're asking
right back bro
all the way to the garage
or something like that that's more than
enough for you guys
that's that's enough for you guys
the big question is does it have a porch
like this the big question is does it
have a porch like this yeah
coffee
they're here
I don't know it's a good number
no look on a piece of paper you've got
the house
well I I just thought maybe
you know
now
we'll try try to confirm that that's
what the price is
you oh okay
yeah just try to confirm
yeah so maybe we can make something
happen
we might be able to make something
happen if all the people that watch
these videos feel like helping you guys
out yeah that would be a that would be a
major way to help you guys out I lost
someone with a clean up all either huh
you know we was clean up all our paper
there I'm like two to the wine
thank you
but they might come back out here again
I don't know
I think I might get your phone number
I'm sure
[Music]
so how the house is empty now
nah David you got furniture
in the summer now I heard about the car
now they told me that you want but the
last time the first time what I've told
them that today
and see they're working right now she
don't want to get to us
maybe we can make something happen
you know if everybody donates five bucks
or maybe even less than that you know if
everybody watches a video donuts five
bucks or less I think that would go
better
that is hard
I would explain it to her last night
not too much money for the house you
know
I might talk a minute tell me a lower
price yeah that's common I have brought
up the road
coming down yep
almost four years
how much
fifty thousand yeah I have been uh four
years
they won't pay for that much for them
it's true yeah it's gonna be hard to
find a buyer in this neighborhood
yeah it might be in backplate somewhere
it'd be different
you know that's a good point yeah
I'll tell you that much for it
yeah we can
put in an offer and see what they do
I I want to do you think about it
back to Walmart
of a car that car
lot bought the car off of that man
the car lot just got there
I feel like a car they just got tired
out of that man's name
now I'll talk to always
Roanoke Virginia in the morning get the
cattle Bill actually
yeah that's what DMV told me so you get
in the car for Betty you're getting the
car for Betty
oh that's your car
you drive no I'm okay yeah but it's your
car
who do drives Betty's car yeah yeah who
drives Betty's car
oh there he does
in my life
you know when I'm pricing people look
down the road I got nervous yeah yeah
yeah driving could be stressful I might
run anymore it wasn't your thing
just like you didn't want to get in the
ferris wheel no
I guess how much Betty's paid for
take a walk out
21.
no no 2021
what year what year no what year
21 yeah about 12.
2012. okay good
I don't know five six
dollars
thousand dollars
God I wouldn't mind kill you huh
she gave down lord because I know the
woman
that's great Walmart
they come in and beat her up
she won't be a king Hunter
we get high 1500
yeah
so you so you understand how to
negotiate
you know how to negotiate
yeah cause that woman asked for what she
gave for
to me
I thought I could hold on toy
during a couple days you know see what I
can do I know she's gonna come to me
and
and she came up here
since somebody knock on my camper and
open up she told me
when you buy my car
and are you scared
she got yet on her
that's how much you want for she said
fifteen hundred dollars
okay hold on I gotta go over here and
talk to my sister
I came over there and talked to Betty
about it
and she told me she didn't have big pain
I went back over I told her she didn't
have 1500
she said
she's right there she started crying
she's a well how about give me a
thousand dollars for
he said I gotta pay a cotton get them
off my my ass I've gone back
over here she owe somebody some money
she owed she owed somebody some money
yeah
yeah I'll come over here
one thousand dollars for it now
I don't know I got enough
you won't scratch it off and brought so
many I went over I gave her a thousand
dollars I drove her home drove a car
home drove her home and he got got what
you want out of car and I drove the car
back and parked
foreign
where's the car
that loud
oh the mouse over there yeah
yeah oh I didn't even see it
again yeah
you know how to negotiate yeah it was a
good deal
so now you have two cars huh no you have
two cars
y'all got one car one truck oh okay
whatever you know what I mean
that car ride
motorbike
I'm looking for one take five months
I can't
I call it a shin shops what are you and
Ray doing in there you guys making out
like a lot of mice in there there's mice
in there yeah oh geez you guys have a
mouse problem huh
you have a lot of mics got a radiator
we're right raisin there he's laying
down you go to Red yeah you got mice oh
I saw a bun I've heard of them
something that's the dog's path
they're under the chair with rape
all right here there's mice in here
you need some Advil I think
I'm gonna get in here Jamie
all right
yeah pretty good
I can't have pizza that's good too so I
just realized who the young man was
yesterday
the young man that was here with the
young the baby your your your grandson
and your great grandson
I took a photo of
Lorraine and Barbara your sister years
ago and Laureen was holding a little
baby
that little baby was the the young man
that I was that I met yesterday
that was it was it was like 20 years ago
almost 19 years ago yeah yeah right
right and he was about a year old in
that photo I think yeah I'm right here
so that was that was all right branded
me I made friendly he's a baby really
yeah
yeah right handling whenever the baby
yeah but if I could never figure out who
whose child that was it'd be gay BJ's
son grandson yeah yeah
yeah
20 years ago yeah yeah
no she sleeps in the bed there's a
bedroom back there oh okay
okay
she and Timmy's sleeping in the bed
together
mine real quick if somebody bought her
he's up there before you know it your
daughter Betty
what's going on with her
brother his mom
his mom your your daughter
she what
about the cow
oh she's in your camper right now yeah
oh is that right
yeah
um
Jack doesn't even know he's missing a
leg
yeah
you have to play all the time
they go
laughs
dogs are amazing aren't they
things missing up missing a leg doesn't
even know it doesn't act like
he's having Timeless life
hey yo hurry no they're just playing
they're just playing
Kenny you working no that ain't working
what do you do with your time now
you hang on the porch
life is slow down here yeah
if I don't bother me nothing down there
is that BJ okay BJ right there
showed me where's the car was yeah
can I put you on camera
this is Larry's daughter yeah Betty
right DJ yep
a big guy
my name is
n't that your name or BJ yeah yeah you
got two betties
Larry Larry was a good dad
yep the best dad ever
what are your memories of growing up in
this family
good memories
no
always been kind to everybody
you remember your grandparents
no
my grandma passed away yeah
yeah
well your mama passed away in 81. hey
and I was two
okay I was two and three
and they passed away I met your son
yesterday
which one
uh what's his name
who didn't meet yesterday huh who did he
meet yesterday at my boys your grandson
good looking boys thank you
but you already got two more than they
met
that was that right
I've got five kids all together yeah
five kids you live down the street and
uh
that's I was there once right
the double one
is that where he met us at
our house
I make you up here yeah no but I
followed you down to your house yeah
yeah
that's right yeah
how was y'all's trip
it's good
fun at the State Fair Timmy and Lorraine
had the blast yeah
do you have fun stay there hey
[Music]
you went on the ferris wheel can't
remember
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
people ain't about like that
he's human yeah
[Music]
Ray wouldn't get on anything
really yeah
regular just too many more he does Ken
is that right I offered to come up here
right here
Ray trust Ray trust you yeah
I often come up here and watch that yeah
let's go back let's go back with you
yeah oh yeah I think Jenny wants to go
back and spend all day there yeah
yeah you want to ride the ferris wheel
again Timmy Timmy
Clicker
Timmy wants to go on the faster rides I
like getting on that one ride when I say
I want to get on oh
get down
and your feet be up here all right when
you come back up you hit me up here
I would want to come out it was the
right one I know what you're talking
about but everywhere we went everywhere
we went in the State Fair people are
stopping them all the time yeah
I watch on TV every night I don't know
how many people stop to talk to him
you guys are celebrities now yeah
said right take a picture with some
woman right in the pig with the woman
right there Ray likes the ladies yeah
you know he's like walking like this
hey
check your hand anything
no he's not shy
it makes me mad and
I'm easily the football
game right here in the bathroom and the
man sat there and you did you know that
one of the things the reason
to tell the stranger slap some of the
back while he's taking a leak
he starts yelling I think the guy was
cool yeah
quit biting his paw
you don't hear him oh you notice I'm
here now didn't you
you notice I'm here dude yeah I love you
too
hey buddy
I don't know how many families
I don't think there's very many families
that
can hang out like this all of you guys
together
every day right now
I go home you're all together I come
back up here about nine o'clock 9 30.
hang out maybe you can do it again
each other you ever get sick of each
other you ever get sick of each other
nope nobody gets on anyone's nerves
if you're human I
mean we do it get around hang down
forward the dog wants right to go back
Bridget where's Jason
he's out there his wife either somewhere
yeah
yeah leave me a pop-up camper that's
right
yeah he keep on asking
everybody gonna come out we don't know
all right boys
you lying every question Yeah Yeah my
two years
yeah yeah
hey John you're a bunch of lie yeah that
happens a lot a lot of people do that
yeah it makes another person mad at you
she's done
I don't trust him all his brother
I know I don't
yeah this house could do some work
though you're scared of the mice
I've seen some so good right come on
outside
come on outside
you're brave Lauren that's all I can say
yeah they're in here
oh you're like
Ray has days like this or he just like
isolates himself
when he goes out though he's so bright
yeah you need to get him out of the
house more
we want to hang out with you Ray
you're my favorite don't tell anybody
else
you want to come outside Ray
okay
what are you gonna do
well
I think we might just we might just take
off
number five yeah yeah
you got it done how you gonna see me
right now that you're ready to go
huh
you're gonna say two once they get home
put on this refrigerator
[Music]
yeah
good job
keep it up
[Music]
leave it in her
[Applause]
when I woke him up
got the hook cutting they just take them
out there woman
oh yeah
I know they're hot
I'll tell you what you get ready one of
those right there he's one of these
things
when they hot peppers Ray likes the hot
peppers
jalapenos jalapenos
they burn my mouth
Ray's got a stomach of iron
he's got a stomach of iron
I know he does
all right well it was nice seeing you
guys
we'll see if we can help you guys maybe
find another house to live in that'd be
nice for everybody
that's a big ask though that's an
expensive house
we're driving to Charlotte now North
Carolina yeah
myself
your your family your family's
originally from uh Virginia right yep
yep
yeah your parents right
yeah yeah I don't know what part
of course
Virginia
what's your favorite memory as a kid
Larry why
memory
what's your favorite memory of being a
kid
that's right back right about
it they had to work oh really
time times are tough back then
yeah where's party around
yeah
baby what do you remember Kenneth
well I remember I went through again and
fight all the time
and Larry helped me
I was the main one
y'all want to talk about me
now where I got it from
yeah
and I I slapped him what did they tell
you I hate that way
it's dirty oh okay
he does
that before
you get a job before no I didn't even
myself where'd the heck go to court yeah
we just fine
those kids again
because they know how their their kids
were
murder murder
they will
kids have kids have it very different
now don't they
kids have it very different now don't
they yeah oh yeah
even I've told my kids all the time I
said y'all are lucky
if I did that when I was younger son
I got my ass for it
stay in trouble when she was come on
blaggy
you're a good dog
Betty what do you remember about your
childhood
before
I don't think I've asked you that before
same answer too
what's that again
this guy that we went to church with in
Sophia
and he would call me telephone he said
there was a telephone
because I had no stuff to happen while I
was in school oh I see but I knew it
when I got home
[Music]
they jumped you mommy
your mommy
yeah
oh Gary man we used to say there was a
telephone a Telegraph and a television
oh because I would know stuff to happen
while I was at school and I knew about
the time I got home
you spread rumors
I just told what I mean
here come on Telegram
[Music]
Chase my sister with the dead snake
I don't remember that
when we lived in Oceana
I had a bunch of kids go down there by
the creek
and I was letting the kids shoot Creek
water into me
with needles
kids do crazy stuff here don't they
I wanted to go swimming
so I saw my daddy's paycheck and went to
the full time by my me and my sister
so
and they call what colorful
try again
she learned it from somewhere
around 12.
and then I got on top of the hill
come off the hill on my big wheel
and
ran into this man's car it's a brand new
Trans Am
en
for more of my head hit it
thank you Daddy got any of my paperwork
to do
huh
they were putting them again in that car
yeah it did it had my head print on the
side of it
and then I remember one time I was
coming off the hill there and soaked by
where the town hall is oh yeah and they
had it they had it stringed off because
they had flea markets on the weekends
ready
yeah yeah
and then and then then to this day God
must have been with me when I was like
what two or three years old
I used to see my mom bring strings off
of my clothes all the time
you can't go nowhere and I couldn't get
my mom up
and I got my mom's lighter and I had a
string hanging and when I burned it when
I went to Bernie it set my whole dress
on fire oh no
when she opened her eyes I was standing
there in flames
you know what I mean like
a kid
his name was you grow up
last time I keep her out of trouble you
guys are interesting family
I had my first kid at the age of 16.
yeah yeah
sorry
you like living here DJ
hey it's all right living here
don't bother me
yes I have
okay
you can't get back boy again
calm down
come down buddy come down calm down
what we're about come on let's go find
the bone come on
why you gotta let me up
business page
yeah okay
yeah hello
hey
hey how are you yeah you called did not
do Tom
yeah she's right here it's about his new
best friend
Tage from Alabama hello
there
in my legs and I'm just my legs are
working then I like walking
[Music]
it's all because your knees hurting
I'm gonna bring your Advil
you need it
we'll see you guys
bye
foreign